the southwest valley will officially be
home to the station casino's newest
property and there was a groundbreaking
a little earlier today for the durango
casino and resort if you live nearby
it's located not too far from durango
into 215 near ikea and the uncommons and
victoria saha live right there with what
people in the area are saying about
their new neighbor
denise and brian for many years there
has been a sign here and now it's
official this dirt lot behind me will
transform into durango casino and resort
many living here are looking forward to
a neighborhood casino
a monumental day for station casinos a
plan that has been in the works for many
years is finally becoming a reality one
of the things entices this area was the
possibility that there would be a casino
right here on the corner of 215 and
durango so
here we are david weiser moved to this
area more than eight years ago hoping
durango casino and resort would be built
the closest place for us where we
usually go is red rock and
you know that's a little bit of a trip
station casino's president scott krieger
says it will be the next best thing
since red rock for this area we're going
to create something that's very social
and open and has a lot of energy
has a very warm and comfortable desert
motif this location will have a 100
thousand square feet of casino
convention and entertainment space
plenty of restaurants as well as a pool
and sports book i think it's really
exciting i think the more life
there is the better
restaurants and entertainment i think is
a huge opportunity for people that need
jobs for people that want to have fun
people living in this area say they felt
very content with what they already had
but the only thing was missing was the
casino and now they will finally get one
station casinos has invested 750 million
dollars into this property it will
create more than one thousand job
opportunities and they hope to open by
late 20-23 reporting from the southwest
valley tonight victoria saha live local
now